Western Powers have criticized Russia's
decision to Halt a deal allowing Ukraine
to export grain from ports in the Black
Sea the Kremlin says it's suspending the
agreement in retaliation for a drone
attack against its Fleet moored off the
coast of occupied Crimea EU foreign
policy Chief Joseph Burrell called on
Russia to reverse its decision to help
avoid a global food crisis and U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken urged
Moscow to stop weaponizing food the U.N
brokered grain deal has seen more than 9
million tons of grain exported from
Ukraine during the war and helped to
bring down surging Global Food prizes
for more I'd like to bring in at DW's
Russia analyst Constantine Eggert in
Vilnius Lithuania Constantine good to
see you again this deal was agreed in
September to avert famine since then
we've seen ships carrying desperately
needed grain they've been able to get
out of Ukraine so what are the
ramifications of Russia pulling out of
this agreement now
well it depends now whether Russia
really wants to renegotiate this deal
and if yes then on which conditions what
are going to be the conditions because
uh otherwise it is going to be Action
Replay what we saw in spring with lots
of especially poorer countries saying
they will like grams actually going to
be hungry or at least malnutrition in
dozens of countries I think that in my
mind Putin is using it deliberately this
incident uh this attack or a legend
attack on the Russian Black Sea Fleet to
return attention to himself and to turn
away attention from the uh the losses he
suffered and
basically the lack of success for his
own Army immigraine in the last weeks I
think that also puts Prussia on
the Turkish president who actually
helped to negotiate this deal in Spring
and this may bring turkey back into
negotiations picture again
so in addition to aiming to shift
attention is there any indication that
Russia is hoping to renegotiate this
deal
well I think that it is in Putin's Habit
to impose new conditions when he sees it
fit and in such circumstances once he
stopped once he again basically he hints
at reinstating the blockade of the
Ukrainian grain ships I think he would
want something more now from this deal
that's my suspicion but it remains to be
seen whether the negotiations will
restart at all and what about these
allegations of the attack uh the Drone
attack what do you make of them
well I think
um
some of Vladimir zielinski's Ukrainian
president's advisors already hinted on
social media that it was an attack
obliquely though uh I think that it is a
huge embarrassment for the Russian
government because it already lost its
Flagship of the Black Sea Fleet the
Moscow Cruiser uh early a few months ago
now it seems judging by at least some
reports unconfirmed reports that uh
another Flagship uh the Destroyer
Admiral Makarov was uh badly hit in this
incident let's put it like that I'm sure
that there is a very bad feeling about
it in Moscow because it seems that the
Black Sea Fleet of Russia cannot defend
itself and this of course provokes Putin
into retaliating and what he did he
retaliated by basically abrogating or at
least suspending the grain deal okay
thank you very much for that update
that's Constantine I got for us in
Vilnius
I'm now joined by Walter fighting a
former Brigadier General in the Austrian
Army who's now president of the
vienna-based think tank the center for
strategic analysis uh welcome sir again
Russia says the deal is off because of
an attack on its Black Sea Fleet what
more details do we have about this
attack
currently we do not have many details
about that because we know in war times
it is not possible to have an
investigation so you have to rely on the
information you get from the official
media and we know that we are in a
propaganda world so no more details at
the moment but I would say militarily
seen it is possible to accept such an
attack
well as you surely know without
providing any evidence Russia claims the
British military helped the ukrainians
in the attack How likely is that
that's a very important point because it
it is the same story because nobody can
can check it so to speak and in times of
a propaganda War it is very easy to
blame the other side to make them
responsible for something that nobody
can check again so it is not very likely
from my understanding because what would
be the Strategic goal of that I do not
see any strategic sense in such a
behavior
Russia is also accusing the British
military for taking part in blowing up
the Nordstrom pipelines in the Baltic
Sea last month what do you make of those
claims
I would say
again what could be the political aim
for strategic aim of that and we have
already a response from the military
side from UK side and then Admiral said
that the UK Navy is not even in in a
position to take such attacks so they
cannot do it they cannot execute
as long as we have you here we want to
take advantage of your expertise and and
talk about what's going on in the
battlefield what is the state of
fighting right now as far as you know it
and what is likely ahead
it's an interesting point because we saw
that the situation was changing to
nearly to the opposite I would say that
we have seen in May or June this year
what do I mean by saying that we see
that the Russian side is not really in a
position to continue their attacks on
the ground so they have a double
strategy nowadays the first part of it
is to defend and to control the
territory I have already conquered and
the second part is to put the rest of
Ukraine under permanent pressure by
sending them close missiles rockets and
drones and so on so keep them away is
the one part and and consolidate the
territory you have already is the other
part on the Russian side and the
Ukrainian side I see a strong attempt to
achieve more on the ground so we have a
text in the North in the east of khakif
to luhan's goblas and in the south of
Castle because Iran
inside has to steal a strong breaches on
the western western part of the Nepal
River and that is what is under attack
by Ukrainian side and that is very
important not to freeze the conflict
some of their understanding but to gain
momentum and to continue their attacks
Walter fighting the center for strategic
analysis in Vienna many thanks
what's a pleasure